what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with paulina pompliano
what's up looking like a highlighter in
the all yellow
what's up anthony pompeo i actually know
this is your favorite color highlighter
yellow for all you who don't know i love
highlighter yellow loves highlighter i
like black
i like highlighter why do you think the
lunch
lunch box and lunch money is highlighter
yellow bang bang
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto
um you have a crypto bearing interest
account
ooh what can you earn 8.6 percent ap why
nice and you remember the third product
oh yes hold on
it's a it's a loan yes against oh it's a
loan against your crypto collateral
nice go check out blockfy.com
lunchmoney to learn more go do it go do
it go do it blockfit.com
lunch money what's up with jerome powell
jerome powell made a speech this morning
jerry stock picker what up
the federal reserve announced the major
policy shift
saying that it is willing to allow
inflation to run
hotter than normal in order to support
the labor market and broader economy
in a move that chairman jerome pound
called a robust updating a fed policy
the central bank formally agreed to a
policy of average
inflation targeting that means it will
allow inflation
to run moderately above the fed's two
percent goal for some time
thoughts bad idea
bad idea good in the short term bad in
the long term
nope wait why bad all around every time
you hear that they're going to let
inflation go higher remember that means
that they're going to take
the purchasing power of the bottom 50 of
americans they are literally going to
steal the wealth of the bottom 50
percent
they're going to widen the wealth
inequality gap and they're going to do
all of this under the guise of oh we
need to
stem economic activity can i just say
you don't let the free market rain can
you say it's wild that they can like
manipulate all that stuff
also can i ask what do rich people do
when inflation is hotter than normal
they just hold assets asset prices
explode
when you have inflation in asset prices
you mean like houses
stocks real estate precious metals
bitcoin all of this stuff is gonna
explode so if you're holding cash your
purchasing power is destroyed
but the people who hold assets that are
denominated in dollars
their value goes up literally it takes
more dollars to buy the same ass
as the dollar gets devalued it's a
simple system that's what they're going
to do they're literally telling you
it's like showing up to a basketball
game and the opposing coach
says to you our strategy today is we're
gonna shoot three pointers
from the corners and the top of the key
that's our strategy
what would you do you would go guard the
corners in the top of the key you would
prevent them from doing that
they're telling you we are going to
devalue your cash that's what they just
said this morning
we are going to devalue your cash at a
higher rate than we have in the past
go and invest savers are losers you get
crushed
investors are already i i've had a long
standing conspiracy theory
hypothesis that anthony is actually
psychic he's like he's like with one of
those balls
so last year before any of this happened
we were all like drinking some wine
everybody was happy
and suddenly out of nowhere anthony goes
i think uh
interest rates are gonna drop to zero
and then i think uh there's gonna be
heavy inflation and i think and i was
just like where is this coming from
somebody there said that it wasn't going
to happen yeah
well it wasn't me here we are all right
what's up with the jobless claims this
makes me so sad everything i know
thursday though i this this how many how
many this you didn't see me earlier when
i was putting the topics together but i
got sad
so the number of americans who filed for
unemployment benefits for the first time
came in another million 1 million for
the 22nd
time in 23 weeks as the economy
struggles to recover i don't know if
it's gonna work out so it totaled just
over a million
down from 1.1 million last week
look until the economy recovers people
are going to still keep losing their
jobs we got to be close to
uh we're over 55 million people now have
lost their jobs so we're probably close
to almost 60 million people have lost
their jobs
look oh my gosh so crazy yeah remember
the highest it had ever been before
this year in a single week was there's
about 700
000 unemployment first-time unemployment
claims in 1980 i feel like this is like
the
should be the stocks are stocks are up
who cares stocks are that is dropped
because
because yeah exactly in 2008 when
everything crashed like this is all
we're talking about now stocks are up
stocks are up we're all making money
stocks are up that's what's going on
right now
nobody wants to talk about the truth and
the truth is there's 60 million
americans who have lost their jobs
and literally we have a federal reserve
that rather than
allow the free market to reign is
practicing interventionism economics
that's all that happens the belief that
we can use
government spending and taxation and
inflation
to drive economic activity is a fallacy
you can't use this stuff to get to full
employment but it's always been done
like that right
no it hasn't that that's the lie that is
the lie that it has not always been done
that way
and actually i personally believe what
they are doing
is making the economic data worse rather
than helping
but if okay it's like it's like saying
this you're really tired it's like
saying you're really tired
right and you should go to sleep your
body's telling you take a nap take a nap
take a nap take a nap recover repair
yourself recover
and instead what do you do you go do
lines of cocaine and drink a bunch of
coffee and you're like
jacked up and it's like oh i'm fine i'm
fine i'm fine all you're doing is you're
just
delaying the inevitable and you crash
harder later but i think when
you don't have these mechanisms in place
you get something like the great
depression
no you see this again a fallacy the
economic
reaction to the situation actually drove
the great depression
it was bad decision making if you allow
the free market in i think it was 1918
or 1919 i forget the exact year
there were 1818 was the spanish flu so i
came here it was 19 or 1919 there was a
big economic shock to the system
right the spanish flu and guess what
happened
nobody did anything the free market
corrected it within 12 months it was
fixed
but the but the people watching
documentary on that but the problem is
that they can't withstand these people
have no stomach for pain
it's the feeling that we have to do
something we have to do something we
don't do something we're not in control
let the free market run what we are
being told is there are companies
they're horrible companies there are
literally companies who are losing money
they are not sustainable companies and
rather than letting them fail
allowing those resources and those
assets to then get transferred into
other more economically viable and
innovative things
instead we're prolonging the inevitable
by giving them money and stuffing money
all in the economy
get out of the way allow
the free market to do its job when you
practice interventionism
and you look at it as a way for
government spending
and taxation to drive full employment
it doesn't work we are making the
situation worse we should allow it to go
when they say that they're going to
print more money and they're going to
create they're intentionally going to
create a
level of high inflation they're going to
overshoot two percent
moderately for a per a long period of
time
think about what they're saying they are
literally going to take away the wealth
of the bottom 50 percent
it's absurd he really hates inflation
okay because it just
it it's the single greatest contributor
to wealth inequality in the world
is the fact that we literally have a
small group of people
you that most of you watching this can't
even name you can name jerome powell you
can't name anybody else who's making
these decisions
and that small group of people are
determining the livelihood
and the prosperity of tens of millions
if not
a hundred percent doing it for the
overall
good of the system they don't
know that they can do that and in fact i
would argue
that jerome powell's not even an
economist he's literally not even
economist
he has a legal background he's a private
equity investor so
no what they're doing is they're they're
simply trying to stabilize asset prices
that's the difference is they are trying
to protect the investors
they're not trying to protect the
average citizen and the investors
or the rich people it is really sad that
we're not going to be talking about
people standing in line getting
unemployment until the stock market
crashes
of course and by the way they're
basically making a commitment to
continue
just inflating asset prices so the the
at the end of the day the problem is
that the people who are affected by this
don't know what's going on they can't
say anything
and so it's the responsibility of the
people who understand this by the way
i'm not getting hurt by this
i'm making money off of this but what
i'm saying is it shouldn't be that way
but my job your job anyone's job who's
doing this is
we're not going to change the system we
can't stop them from doing this you have
to position
yourself to benefit from it rather than
be hurt by but that doesn't mean that
it's the right thing for them to do it's
just they're going to do it either way
yeah so the nuance is get educated
protect yourself
position yourself to benefit rather than
get hurt by it but still
call out this is nonsense this is
complete nonsense i was talking to my
dad the other day
who has been on this show and i was
telling him about
evo inflation and what they're planning
to do probably and whatever he was like
i've seen this before
yeah literally this is exactly what
happens this is the path
to a currency being right but they've
done that before
the u.s has played with the
leverage it's the only two tools that
they have and it didn't become zimbabwe
so no one's saying that it has to go to
hyperinflation become zimbabwe
what we're saying is that the u.s
dollar's purchasing power is down
98 since 1913.
if you held a dollar and could buy
something worth one dollar
you now can only buy something that is
the equivalent of two cents
yeah 98 so again you can't do anything
to change it no matter how
upset i get how upset you get how upset
you get
you cannot do anything to stop this the
only thing you can do is get educated
education is a great equalizer position
yourself
so that you benefit from what's going to
happen rather than get hurt by it that's
it
okay let's move on ready yes i feel bad
for kevin mayer
yeah what happened to him so tick tock
ceo kevin mayer has quit the company
like four months after he joined from
disney he said in his letter
in recent weeks as the political
environment has sharply changed i have
done significant reflection
on what the corporate structural changes
will require and what it means for the
global role i signed up for
against this backdrop as we expect to
reach a resolution very soon
it is with a heavy heart that i want to
let you all know that i have decided to
leave the company
did he decide to leave the company or
was he kind of pushed out
i think this is he definitely was oh he
definitely
it's his doing you think yeah why
because he walked into a
[ __ ] [ __ ] storm right yeah but but so
he's saying
i didn't sign up for this job i didn't
sign up i signed up to run a
technology company i didn't sign up to
be a pawn in a geopolitical
battle oh my god i'd be out there so
fast so look kevin
mayer's out the uh you think he wants to
join lunch money
maybe he's fantastic like from
everything i've heard everything i've
read bob iger etc they all speak very
very highly of them so
kevin sorry all right i get it global
bank heist
hackers tied to the north korean
government are trying to rob banks
across the globe by draining atms and
initiating fraudulent money transfers
in an effort by the cash strap cash
strapped
pyongyang regime did you like how i said
that
to fund its nuclear weapons program
so spear phishing attacks north korea is
being sanctioned
left right and center they've been cut
off from the global financial system
so when you make somebody desperate what
do they do they do desperate things
of course we've known for a long time
that north korea is behind a lot of
hacks right i mean
literally they hacked sony if you
remember that do you remember that
documentary we watched on north korea's
hacking
yeah it's good it's pretty global like
it's like state it's not state-sponsored
like oh let me just give
the money she does it it's like planet
come here sit down like you're literally
going to be a hacker now
like like though it was pretty crazy
give me the money
i don't know north korea blows my mind
yeah
it's pretty crazy i'm obsessed with
three things
ready they all kind of have like well
you but they all kind of have like
things in common
north korea cults and the mafia
literally those three things are all the
same pretty much pretty much right
all right what's next amazon oh this is
fascinating
amazon's unveiling halo to battle apple
watch and fitbit
it's tracking activity body fat and
emotions it looks kind of sleek
i'm not gonna lie this is their first
significant move into wearables
which gartner estimates will be a 52
billion dollar market this year
and and this is what i want to tell you
okay so
literally it tracks users emotional
state by listening to the tone of their
voice and tells you you have some
negative emotion
can you yeah we would i mean my tone of
voice with you
it goes up it goes down and goes
sideways but sometimes i'm joking and
it doesn't know that i'm joking i would
probably be like paulina like
you know i would no what amazon would
say is it would say the things i want to
say but i'm not allowed to say like yo
you need to chill out right now
no but the new fitbit also has a chill
out function that tells you like you're
getting
it i'm gonna get you i should have got
you a fitbit no but but
okay so do you think people will buy
this knowing that amazon is listening to
them
that they're aware they put the things
in their houses yeah that's true
yeah people don't people are dumb they
just buy the things that are would you
buy it
no would you buy from me no but look at
how cool it looks like
activity sleep tone of voice and it
tells you literally your mood
how positive how neutral
it would be setting off alarms right now
after my rant on influence oh man it
would feel your heart going all right
what's up with
but are we thinking that this is a good
idea
yeah of course i mean they have to do
you think they're gonna win uh i don't
think there will be one winner
they'll all share parts of the mind all
right cool all right you're going to
like this ready
that photo shoot he did with the crown
yeah sotheby's is having a hip-hop
auction and they're selling his crown
how much
uh 300k that's really not that much is
it
compared to what that is it is estimated
to solve for 300k it could go
more there's also uh there's also
another thing that's a set of love
letters from a teenage tupac
which were written between 1987 and 88
to his high school girlfriend kathy loy
when he was 16 years old the letters
detailed the pair's two-month
relationship
including a letter of regret sent a year
later and also offer insight into
tupac's friendship with his classmate
jada pinkett who is will smith's wife i
believe
they're estimated to be worth six
between 60k and 80k
so if anybody's interested i'd rather
the crown than the love letters of
course same
fit for king so
i'm curious celebrities said what else
is in the auction but i think it's
interesting
what uh i personally like the crown just
because biggie's the man
yeah are you a biggie or a tupac fan i'm
a biggie fan yeah good
good good uh all right ready for my joke
sure
what do you call a person missing 75
percent of their spine
well they're going to say soul and i was
going to say polina um
a really all right all right chill
i'm joking hostage video
of course uh 75 of their spine
yeah spineless what a quarterback
you didn't think that one's funny i
thought that was hilarious go back
are you now on the reddit the dad jokes
subreddit adam sent me and i will be
here from now on all right guys that's
it for lunch money today please send
help
while the well what is it while washing
is trying to get rich the rest of us is
trying to get our lunch money right
go check out block five block five dot
com slash lunch money
i need a new co-host she literally
walked off the set yesterday i'll see
you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends